افادت مراسله الجزيره في واشنطن انا مالا
يقل عن 19 شخصا لقوم مصرعهم بسبب العاصفه
الثلجيه التي تضرب مناطق واسعه في
الولايات المتحده والتي تسببت في انخفاض
قياسي لدرجات الحراره ادت العاصفه الى
الغاء اكثر من 1500 رحله اليوم السبت خاصه
في مطارات ديترويت وشيكاغو ومن يا بوليس
ودنفر وياتي هذا بعد الغاء نحو سته الاف
رحله جويه الجمعه واغلاق مطار بابالو
تماما على وزير النقل ان الثلج والجليد
عاملان اساسيان وراء العديد من الالغاءات
وارتفع عدد منازل التي عانت من انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي لاكثر من مليون
و600 الف
ثانيه نظم الينا مراسلنا ناصر الحسيني
ناصر ما هي المناطق الولايات الاكثر تضررا
من العاصفه
في هذه الاثناء
في الشمال الشرقي الان تعاني من رياح
عاتيه وبعد الثلوج التي تزيد من خطورتها
تلك الرياح التي تدفع بها باتجاه المدينه
تم منع التجول الان في المدينه هناك
تقارير تتحدث عن
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
العاصفه الثلجيه في بافلو في هذه اللحظه
همم هي بدرجه هي بقوه بدرجه ان رجال
المطافي ايضا الذين يسعون لين قد الناس
خصوصا في سياراتهم ايضا اصبحوا ضحيه لهذه
الموجه العاتيه من الرياح في فقر الولايات
المتحده ايضا نفس الرياح القويه ومازاله
العاصفه مستمره في الشمال في الشتاء في
موتانا كلها ولايه تعيش حاليا تحت وطاه ان
لم تكن الثلوج قد مرت هي تعيش الان تحت
موجه من البرد القارس لم تشهد الولايات
ايه ده حقيقه المتحوله 40 عاما في واشنطن
العاصمه حيث واقف الان درجه الحراره ناقص
10 مئويه في مدن مثل حتى هذه العاصفه
بنطاقها الواسع
وباعتبارها تاريخيه الى حد ما لم تصل ابدا
الى الجنوب الامريكي هذه المره امتدت
العاصفه الثلجيه وعاصفه البرد القارس الى
حدود ولايه التنس جنوبا وهي ايضا درجات
تحت الصفر الى ولايه تكساس في كوبايات
المدن
واعاده مدن ساخنه لا تشهد مثل هذه العواصف
هذه المره عاصفه واسعه نطاق من حيث
الجغرافيا تتوجه الان نحو الشباب الشرق
وتتركز في وجه خاص في هذه اللحظه في
الشمال الشرقي نيويورك في مدينه بافلوه
التي تدفع ثمن باه ايضا حتى الان في مستوى
الحياه العامه بطاقه
المشلوله الان في كل هذه الولايات حول عشر
الولايات تقريبا هذا معه رغبه الناس في
السفر ااا في من اجل اعياد الميلاد
وبالتالي حركه السفر وقفت الاف الرحلات تم
الغائها 1500 رحله لهذا اليوم فقط